three days into the impeachment trial
house democrats wrap up their arguments
saying former president trump must be
punished for lighting a match
that led to the january 6 riot on
capitol hill
democrats need 17 republican senators to
vote to convict the former president
the trump legal team lays out its case
tomorrow we'll have more on all of that
in just a moment
but first president biden says his
administration has purchased enough
vaccine
to vaccinate every american this as the
administration continues to go back and
forth on when to send
send kids back to school when schools
will reopen
and what exactly the definition of open
is
white house correspondent peter ducey
with the story live from the north lawn
good evening peter
good evening brett the president's
announcement they have secured 200
million more doses of covet vaccine
which is enough for 100 million more
people
comes on the eve of a really big test
will
teachers unions whose leaders
overwhelmingly support
biden but whose members have refused to
return to school on schedule
listen to new cdc guidance about what's
safe
just this afternoon we signed the final
contracts for
100 million more moderna and 100 million
more pfizer vaccines
are also able to move up the delivery
dates with an additional
200 million vaccines to the end of july
faster than we expected president biden
toured a lab at the national institutes
of health has his kova 19 team hinted
at what's in tomorrow's cdc announcement
about reopening schools
we know that if for example dr wolinski
says that all the kids are wearing masks
and there's a certain number of kids in
the school and there are certain other
set of conditions we should be opened
and we should be open as much as
possible the white house's goal for
reopening schools surprised some on
tuesday
teaching at least one day a week in the
majority of schools
by day 100.
[Music]
because 66 of k-12 students are already
back
at least once a week according to school
tracking data the president will not
rest
until every school is open five days a
week
the president is pushing for a 1.9
trillion dollar coven 19 stimulus
package but
even before that's added to the bottom
line the congressional budget office
projects this country's debt
will soon be bigger than the entire
economy although
big deficits weren't a big problem for
biden during the transition there's a
reason why the federal government
is able to run a deficit because the
states must
must balance their budgets despite a
pledge not to follow
impeachment president biden has seen
some democratic exhibits he was
impacted by the video as a human being
and now has an opinion about the chances
of a trump conviction my guess is
some mines may have been changed but i
don't know the president had a long
long distance call last night last night
i was on the phone
for two straight hours with xi jinping
that was biden's first
chat with china as president the
president's view is that
we're in a competition with china
missing from the readout of the call
talk about the origins of kovan 19. he
talked about the fundamental concerns
he has we have about beijing's coercive
and unfair economic
practices ultimately it wasn't a
confrontational call it was a good
conversation i know him well
but biden has changed his tune on china
in 2019 he said
china is going to eat our lunch come on
man
today a 180 degree difference we don't
get moving they're gonna eat our lunch
now closer to dinner time president
biden
is saying he was not upset with the
vaccine rollout plan that was in place
the day he took office he was upset that
he didn't have all the facts
that were available about the vaccine
rollout plan to the prior administration
before he took office brett
peter ducey live on the north lawn peter
thanks thousands